friends and students that that we've
talked to have told us a lot more about
this shooter from what we've heard so
far we're gonna have more on that in
just a moment just a little while ago I
did speak with Jim guard who was a math
teacher here at Stoneman Douglas high he
locked himself and several students
inside his classroom during what was
happened happening and he talked about
what happened yesterday afternoon right
around 2:20 I heard the fire alarm go
off so I told the kids I said look just
hang out for a second
this could just simply be something
accidental then we got a announcement
that said ok evacuate the building like
10 seconds later so in the door the kids
you know took off they were very the
kids are great they're very orderly
so as I'm ready to leave then we hear
all these popping sounds you know
sounding like firecrackers and we heard
mr. Porter came on again he said Code
Red
get back in the room so I Scott yelled
the kids let's go let's get back in here
well there were six kids five girls in
the boy who kind of right there shuttle
them in but then the kids what's
happening I don't know this might be a
drill you know let's assume it's a drill
and then really 20 minutes later we knew
it wasn't so the kids went we're here at
my room now all the other kids what I
did was went on our email and a lot of
teachers are emailing you know these
children are with me these children with
me these are the ones I don't have so I
put on all the six kids who I had and
then the other kids who were absent just
weren't there and here the kids who are
missing to try and find out where they
are
meanwhile my other kids a little cell
phones so we're all texting and we found
that where the other 13 10 out of 13
were and the other three we didn't know
but we found them later on at four
o'clock we got released we're hearing
stories about many teachers like you who
tried to protect the students some cases
took them in closets in some cases may
have shielded these students can you
talk about your fellow teachers and how
they're doing this morning I only know
that our I don't know what news is out
there what names are out there but I
doing that with one of our teachers
apparently was shovel two of them or
shot and killed one was shot killed
standing in front of those kids which
I'm not sure if you guys have his name
released enough but doesn't surprise me
at all I've known him since I got here
in 2008
he was fantastic Carson he went here he
was that you know an eagle he went here
it was great no breasts a great guy
[Music]
friends and students are describing to
us the suspect as a troubled violent
teenager before he was kicked out of
Stoneman Douglas high